all right good people of the Internet it
is April 27th 2020 we are in week 146 of
the quarantine / lockdown I'm Dave Rubin
as you guys know I'm doing these direct
messages about 15 20 minutes every
Monday and Wednesday today is a
particularly big one for us because in
case you haven't heard I've got a book
coming out tomorrow
finally I've been promoting this thing
for about eight months but today is your
last day to pre-order don't burn this
book it's coming out tomorrow I assume a
bunch of the morality in the mail
heading out to you guys I just saw this
morning that we're already an Amazon
best seller which is a pretty beautiful
thing tomorrow we are doing a live
signing for the book we'll be live
streaming it right here on this channel
so if you haven't pre-ordered the book
yet and you want to get a signed book
late and you can ask me a question
during the live stream we've got the
link right down below
it's just premier collectibles dot-com
slash Rubin so today's your last day to
pre-order if you want a pre-order and
you want a signed book plate and you can
ask me a question for the livestream
tomorrow today is it in case you've been
ignoring me for the last eight months
and I'm sure you had your reasons it's
time people you're trapped in your house
I promise you that the ideas in this
book are the right ideas for right now I
finished writing this thing in July we
edited it in the fall but the stuff that
I talk about in this book about states
rights about personal responsibility
finding a mentor thinking for yourself
more importantly about anything else
they're more relevant now actually then
even when I wrote them before just
because of everything going on with
coronavirus so premiere collectibles
calm slash Rubin the link is right down
below you will get a signed book plate
which I'll sign for you live tomorrow
I'm gonna be signing the entire time
through and you can ask me a question
and I'm very excited to to be part of
that oh and by the way if you haven't
seen it already if you go ahead and
pre-order and this is for anyone that's
already pre-ordered if you go to Rubin
report.com slash preset no print but
slash exclusive you can enter your
order confirmation number and you can
see the video that my husband David and
I put up it's an hour long interview he
interviewed me and we talked about
building the show together and meeting
Donald Trump and just the adventure
we've been on and a whole bunch of other
stuff and it's an hour-long interview we
have a little teaser for that on our
YouTube channel where we tell the Donald
Trump story that's that's Ruben
report.com / pre-sale sorry / pre-sale I
got a lot on my mind right now it's
gonna be a crazy crazy two weeks right
now there's just a lot happening okay so
I wanted to talk about this Joe Biden
situation today I didn't really want to
talk about this Joe Biden situation
because when I do these direct messages
this is more my my ability and my desire
just to talk to you directly about sort
of what's going on in my life over the
last six weeks eight weeks whatever it
is now talk to you about what's going on
with lockdown and what are you guys
doing to pass the time and are you
working on new skills and just like all
the things that we're all thinking about
like are we happy at our jobs and what
about telecommuting and we trap with
kids in the house and do we want to do
all these things and like just all about
the new world that's on the horizon but
there was a story in the last couple
days that has gone sort of semi viral
and I say semi viral because it's only
going viral in a certain corner of the
Internet I want to preface everything
that I'm about to say right now by
saying that I am NOT a journalist I have
never said that I am a journalist I do
not purport to be a journalist I
wouldn't even want to be accused of
being a journalist of course that being
said most journalists are actually
journalists meaning that they're not
journalists who are on the quest for
finding truth most of them are activists
who are guys as journalists and we're
seeing an example of that right now one
of the things that I write about in the
book actually there's a whole chapter on
how to spot fake news and I talked about
four types of tape fake news one type
and I think this is the most interesting
type actually because when we think of
fake news we think of like just
blatantly fake stories right like that's
an obvious why don't I talk about that
in the book and then there's another
type which is when there's a headline
that says one thing and then if you read
the article which most people don't even
bother doing you find out that the
headline and the article are almost
polar opposites of each other that's
another type but the type that I'm most
interested in because I think it's the
one that
least amount of people understand is
that a type of fake news is what the
media ignores and we're seeing a version
of that right now so look there have
been these sexual assault accusations
against Joe Biden now we know that when
Brett Kavanaugh the Supreme Court
justice he was just a nominee at the
time when he had accusations against him
for weeks and weeks and weeks this was
the front page of the New York Times
this was CNN Washington Post this was
everything everywhere the though they
were just allegations right and I'm not
saying the media shooter shouldn't have
covered it but we know how the media
reacted when he a conservative had
accusations against him I was actually
on tour with Jordan Peterson during that
time and wherever we went we were in
freaking streets of Dublin I kid you not
and people would come up to me and asked
me about Kavanagh and I was like this is
crazy but people across the world in
Ireland are asking me about the
presumptive you know the nominee for the
Supreme Court like it's just craziness
okay so we know that they that the media
treats people on the right a certain way
and you all know that everybody knows
that right but over the last couple
weeks there have been allegations from a
woman named Tara Reid who's a former Joe
Biden staffer against Joe Biden and she
claims that he sexually assaulted him
now for weeks people have been talking
about this online it's an allegation
much like the Kavanagh allegations are
and I'm not here to say it's true or
that the others were true or that any
allegations are true and I do believe in
due process believe it or not I know
that's an old-school bot but I'm an
old-school guy but the mainstream media
has completely ignored it and then in
the last couple days and this is where
the story really gets interesting in the
last couple of days a clip from an old
Larry King show my man Larry King I'm
talking to him later today by the way
where he used to do live call ins on his
TV show on CNN a clip came out and you
should listen to this clip and then I'll
give it context in just a moment so this
is Larry King Live this is about 25
years ago we're back couple more phone
calls on this very important topic our
guests are former United States Senator
Howard Baker Richard Allen former
national security adviser and Louis
Romano of the Washington Post san luis
obispo
hello yes hello I'm wondering what a
staffer would to do besides go to the
press in Washington my daughter has just
left there after working for a prominent
senator and could not get through with
her problems at all and the only thing
she could have done was go to the press
and she chose not to do it out of
respect for him or she had a story to
tell but out of respect for the person
she worked for she didn't tell it but
these are the people who do come to the
lowest romano's right the staff worker
who says I want to let you know about
what's going on the guy down the hall
mm-hmm and a lot of these people have a
sense of obligation they feel that this
public officials should be accountable
if it's something whistleblowers to the
press
god I love seeing peak Larry King just
like the Tioga and the suspenders oh you
know kind of hunched over the desk I
love it okay so what's interesting about
this clip is it turns out that it is now
confirmed by Tara Reid herself via
Twitter that the woman in that video the
woman who called in to claim that her
daughter had been sexually assaulted by
a senator is Tara Reid's mother now
apparently her mother has passed on
since but she is confirmed that that is
the voice of her mother now that doesn't
make the allegations true but what's
interesting about this and this goes to
what I talked about earlier about a type
of fake news is that everyone Stelter
and Jake Tapper and all the CNN people
they're seeing these clips Anderson
Cooper's seeing these clips all the New
York Times people they're seeing these
clips and much like they've been
covering for Biden's mental state which
everyone knows is deteriorating and by
the way when he either steps down or
gets replaced or whatever whatever's
gonna happen when that thing happens
suddenly there'll be a good jillion
stories about I knew but I was pressured
not to say anything everyone knows it
every everyone backing him right now
even some of the people I like some of
the former candidates whom I've had on
this show we've been they all know what
the deal is but that
that thing where the media ignores
something because it doesn't fit their
narrative that is a type of fake news
again I am NOT saying the allegations
are true the New York Times by the way
he ignored ignored ignored this story
for weeks until they finally did a story
I think on page 23 or 24 and of course
within that had paragraphs and
paragraphs about allegations against
Trump now the point is if you're gonna
talk about allegations against Trump
fine just like you're gonna talk about
allegations of Kavanaugh fine but then
you have to talk about the Biden
allegations - but what the media has
done is become a cheerleading machine
for Democrats and basically a slander
machine against Republicans and it's
it's like this exact type of story that
is turning everyone against mainstream
media and the irony and I say this all
the time but the irony is that
journalists are destroying journalism
right it's not people think it's like oh
it's the online voices that are finally
sticking it to the to the man the man
meaning like mainstream media but it's
it's not like yeah it's great that
there's a plethora of voices it's great
that you guys can find truth and
interesting opinions and the rest of it
elsewhere but it should not fall on
someone like me to have to calmly
explain to you the insanity that's going
on here but what you're gonna see now is
they're gonna keep running cover Stelter
won't touch this and Jake Tapper Jacob
Riis by the way I think it's a decent
human being he's the last guy at CNN
that I think has like a why don't I say
the last but like the last of the main
people that say that I think has like a
spark of like a thought process going on
it isn't basically totally in it for the
Democrat and again they can all do that
if they say that's what they are but
they ignore it long enough then it
catches fire online and then it feeds
the narrative that they're just like a
BS monster basically against Republicans
and by the way this is one of the things
whether you'll like him or not this is
one of the things that John was a John
Travolta but Donald Trump inherently
understood that he had to not only fight
the Democrats but he also had to fight
the Machine so it's uh it's really it's
just crappy more than anything else and
I wanted to bring it to your attention
because you're not going to see this in
mainstream media and I would prefer not
to do this I'd prefer to talk about some
of the other things about this book that
I have coming
tomorrow and if by the way guys if you
go to premiere collectibles calm / Ruben
you can get a signed book playtime
signing them live tomorrow and I'll
answer one of your questions live so
we're very excited about that but oh by
the way my new Praeger u video came out
this morning it's called the bravery
deficit I've done three I think this is
I think this is the best of the three my
two other ones are in their top like 15
I think the why I left I left I think is
their first your second most viewed
video but I really think this one is
just perfect and really perfect for the
moment that we find ourselves in where
there's just so many people afraid to
say what they think so I hope you guys
will check that out as well and and I
want to jump to a couple questions and
by the way I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this type of fake news and
what's going on with the media and
everything else these days because my
twitter feed is just so out of control
and there's just so many responses to
everything and the rest of it and I
can't even deal with Facebook or
whatever if you want to communicate
directly with me and with like-minded
people with no trolls and BOTS join us
at Rubin report comm and we've got an
iOS Apple app and we've got a Google
Play app Android app and we've got just
incredible free thinkers from literally
all over the world and there's no trolls
or BOTS cuz if you're a troll in a bot I
boot yet and by the way that's not deep
platforming I just don't want you in my
house it's my digital home you can't be
there don't like it don't want yeah okay
let's see this is a great question this
I should save this for tomorrow but I'll
do a couple here return to Reason asks
which part of the book was the hardest
to write and why I also just finished
your New Prague or you five minute video
genuinely one of the best Prague or you
videos I've ever seen well I'm glad to
hear that so thank you for that which
was the hardest part you know in many
ways actually it was the first chapter
which was not the first chapter when I
wrote it one of the things that you find
out when you're writing is that things
get moved so the editors come in and
they're like well you know we can build
a different arc this way this way that
way and chapter one was not originally
chapter one it fully makes sense as
chapter one and then I subsequently
changed some things so that it sort of
fed that kind of from the back but in
Chapter one its it's called it's time to
come out and what I talk about is much
like what I'm sort of laying out in the
Prague review video that there is a
political closet right now I mean most
of us think that there's only a closet
into your sexuality but you can be
closeted about anything any thought that
you're not sharing you are closeted
about and when you are closeted it will
lead to a lot of bad stuff so anyone
that's been closeted about their
sexuality or something else like you
know what that leads to like you're
there's only room for one in there and
then you know if there's room for
usually booze and drugs and just a lot
of bad behavior and shame and all that
stuff and I sense that's happening to
people because of politics right now and
it's not because they want to be out out
there as a racist or something like that
but the Machine the woke machine has
actually caused people to fear it and
that's the purpose of the Praeger you
video which is why we released it today
with the book coming out tomorrow
because I want to break that machine I
don't think there is something so
spectacular ly brave about me I just
happened to be doing this thing and I
think I think you guys are ready to do
it too and I think especially especially
especially right now while we're in the
midst of this craziness with the
lockdown and we're seeing people and
states rise up like it's time to start
bringing this thing home like I'm not
I'm not saying it was a hoax or anything
like that like I have been fine with
everything you know I was gonna say I've
been fine with everything we've done I
don't know that I've been fine with
everything we've done especially when
the when the governor of Michigan
decides you're not going to sell seeds
and you can't do landscaping at your
house and the mayor of my city here in
Los Angeles wants to snitch on our
neighbors so not everything has been
perfect but we did social distancing we
seem to have flattened the curve it's
been about two months we got to get back
out there guys and I see a lot of people
now they're starting to say that
privately even when I was at the
supermarket yesterday I had a you know
I'm doing the six foot thing and I got
my mask and it's LA it's 95 degrees in a
dripping and I got plastic gloves on and
it's just miserable but I heard a guy on
the phone behind me talking to he's like
you know and the whole thing is Bo so
it's like people are starting to turn on
this and if you have a healthy
skepticism of government you know this
is one of the interesting things right
now I keep seeing these comedians and
Jimmy Kimmel types like mocking all the
protesters and it's like the protesters
are fighting for our ability to go out
again it doesn't mean they're right
about everything it doesn't mean it's a
conspiracy but I would say at this
moment if we're sort of like at the apex
of this thing and we can either go
lockdown forever or start bringing our
some
some freedoms back while understanding
that maybe that's gonna cause some more
sickness again and there could be second
waves and all that stuff it's like life
does go on it has to go on life finds
away Jeff Goldblum Jurassic Park he's in
a lot of crap this week did you see this
he was a judge on one of those drag
shows and he asked a Muslim woman if
there's a problem in Islam against gays
and now the local police are going after
him and it's like wait a minute woke
people I thought we were four days but I
guess not because the pyramids a little
weird anyway so writing the the chapter
sorry that was a quite a divergent
thought they're writing the chapter
about the closet was the hardest for me
personally because I had to go back to a
time in life that I don't really think
about that had to do with a lot a lot of
depression and not being happy and the
rest of it and I like in my experience
in that to what I think a lot of people
are dealing with now and actually there
was there were probably about an extra
20 page it's really just like devoted to
that thing itself me in the closet that
that we cut that I think will probably
be part of of and maybe my next book or
something else I have an idea for a next
book that maybe won't be as personal or
something but I think you really get
really will dig the book guys and and
I'm psyched that the the numbers have
been fantastic and we're we're in good
shape and and I'm just excited it's like
I feel like I finished this thing so
long ago it's like I'm about to give
birth tomorrow so I'm very excited for
that and I will throw in one more
well Jeffrey quickly asked it I see Tim
Poole's take on the New York Times
article on Biden read case what's your
take on it I didn't see Tim's video on
it but I think you know my feelings
about it right now
Torres lover says what was the Epiphany
that caused you to change your way of
thinking politically how can we
enlighten others to that path I mean
that is literally 100 percent what the
book is about it is about my path my
journey and the tools that you guys will
need to blaze your own Trail I mean one
of the things that I'm really big on in
this book is I'm not trying to convince
anybody to think anything what I want
you to do is think for yourself the
abortion chapter I literally end the
abortion it's not a chapter there's a
section on what I think about specific
issues the
abortion chapter the abortion section
within that chapter I literally end by
saying now that you all hate me let's
move on so what I'm trying to do here is
allow you to think for yourselves and
what I'm trying to lay out is some
classical liberal principles that are
about individual rights and lays a Fair
economics and light touch of government
that's it and I really do think that is
the widest tent in the future I think a
lot of people are waking up to it and in
many ways right now it's sort of all of
us and by all of us I mean it's
libertarians and conservatives and
old-school liberals kind of everybody
against the the sort of progressive
socialists like the people that just
want government to do everything so what
I don't want to get hung up on
progressives or socialists it's just
basically if you want government do
everything it's pretty much everyone
against you and but that's a tough fight
because those are the people that really
get into government so that they can
control it so there's a lot a lot going
on here ok I think that's it for now
because we're trying to keep these short
I am also last week I was literally
sitting in this chair for about 8 9
hours a day doing all sorts of press so
if you haven't seen it my Ben Shapiro
Sunday special just went up over on
Ben's channel on YouTube I did an
interview with Adam Carolla the other
day Dan Crenshaw interviewed me Crowder
interviewed me I'm gonna be on 'pray
Gers radio show this weekend Larry elder
and Seb Gorka and my buddy max Lugo beer
I did his podcast I'm doing Brian
Collins podcast there's like a gajillion
other things oh and I'll be on Tucker
Carlson tonight that's a big one
so the the sort of official television
debut of the book is tonight I will be
on Tucker Carlson he's getting the first
exclusive that's what we call it in the
biz
anyway guys anyway guys one more time if
you go to premier collectibles dot-com
slash Rubin I will sign a book play live
for you tomorrow and you can submit a
question for the live stream I'll answer
anything and everything and it's gonna
be a crazy week as always I thank you
guys for your support I'm feeling sharp
and ready to roll let me know your
thoughts on this Larry King situation or
this Larry King video and just sort of
how the media is playing this thing it's
like and by the way Tapper Stelter
you're watching this thing guys just
report on it you don't have to even
comment on it just say oh this thing
exists and then we wouldn't think you're
so terrible could you do that
throw me a bone here would you do that
alright guys thanks a lot don't burn
this book calm I'll see you tomorrow